many of us may be familiar with the myth
of King Midas and his ability to
transform inanimate objects into gold
but how exactly did he acquire such a
talent Midas ruled over the region known
as Phrygia part of what we call today
modern-day Turkey as you would expect
from a king he lived the life of luxury
and abundance in his large castle with
his only daughter but despite how rich
Midas was nothing bought him as much joy
as accumulating gold he would often
spend vast amounts of time
counting his gold coins his obsession
led to him covering all of his clothing
in gold objects sometimes even going as
far as to bathe in gold
the god Dionysus had passed through
Midas his kingdom but his companion and
longtime friends Salinas had lost his
way after the two had drunk a bit too
much wine the night before Salinas was
found wandering in the gardens of the
surrounding palace by the men of King
Midas upon being recognized Salinas
would spend the next few days enjoying
the hospitality of King Midas as the two
indulged themselves when Salinas had
explained what had happened to him King
Midas did not hesitate in reuniting him
with his friend Dionysus once reunited
Dionysus was extremely grateful to King
Midas for the kindness he had shown he
told the king that as a reward he would
grant him one wish
Midas paused and after a short period of
contemplation he replied I wish that
everything I touched became gold
Dionysus urged the king to reconsider
his wish but Midas was adamant that that
is what he wanted
unable to dissuade the King from his
wish Dionysus asked Midas to heed he's
worn in and granted the wish the
following day when Midas awoke he was
eager to see if he's wish had been
granted reaching over to his bedside
table as midas lay his hands down it did
indeed turn into gold filled of
excitement he began to touch every
object in his room until he was so
exhausted he had to rest as midas sat
down for breakfast he leant over to
smell a rose but as he touched it the
fragrance is gone he was disappointed
that he would never again enjoy the
fragrance of his garden without touching
his flowers every piece of food that
might is touched turned to gold before
he could even reach his lips and it
wasn't long before he began to realize
but the gift he had so eagerly asked for
may not have been a gift when Midas his
daughter entered the room she ran over
to hug her father and as she did tears
filled his eyes as he had just turned
his daughter into a solid gold statue
distraught at what he had just done
midas began to pray to Dionysus to end
this curse Dionysus told Midas to go to
the river pack tellus where everything
he placed in the river would revert back
to normal
midas washed his hands in the river and
felt his newfound power disappeared
leaving a stream of shimmering gold
behind him when he returned home
everything that was once gold had
returned to normal midas hugged his
daughter and he left her in charge of
his kingdom he had realized that all the
riches in the world would no longer make
him happy he retreated to the forest
where he became a follower of the god
Pan and where he would live a simple and
humble life
the story of king midas and his golden
touch is a classic case of be careful
what you wish for midas was a greedy
king who believed that wealth was the
route to happiness and it wasn't until
he lost his daughter the one thing that
he truly loved that he realized he no
longer needed money and material
possessions to live a happy life